there are a lot of things in life worth
caring about things we consider
important and meaningful things that
affect the narrative of our lives but
beneath all the things that construct
our narratives the one thing a human
should take most seriously in life is
not taking life too seriously life is
simply too complicated it is too far out
of our comprehension to claim it as
something that we can take as seriously
as many of us often do we could very
well be characters in some intricate
simulation we could very well be the
most intelligent life forms in the
universe prospective gods to those that
reside beneath us we could very well be
living a reality that it is merely a
projection of each of our individual
consciousness with no root in objective
truth all we could be nothing more than
a collectively evolving bacteria
destined to feed off the planets of the
universe with zero purpose or benefit to
anything outside of ourselves some
possibilities regarding our existence
bear a bleak outlook for humanity others
suggest promising idealistic ones either
way we do not know and we may never know
therefore we must not let trivial
inconveniences and troubles affect us
too much in life because what a shame it
would be to live a life filled with
stress worry and concern for things that
end up not even being real or important
things we could have chosen to ignore
would it not be the safer bet to work
towards enjoying life floating with the
tides adapting to new situations and not
letting things ruin our ability to
embrace life's profound mystery
it is important that we care about the
things that we deem relevant and
meaningful in life but it is equally
important to live with the
acknowledgement that it could all just
be losery
nothing more than a crazy dream or trip
of the mind with no real relevance or
stake in anything beyond the mere
experience of it and the best way to
embrace this and maximize the experience
is to try our best to be light-hearted
and fluid to laugh at our problems so we
can cry tears of joy over life's wonder
[Music]
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this videos
please give it a thumbs up share your
thoughts in the comments below and if
you are not already be sure to subscribe
to our Channel we are constantly coming
out with new videos to help you
experience life with clarity and Wonder